[Music]
did you watch this video no is this like
spawn i get that it's in dubai but is it
sponsored by like [ __ ] british
petroleum
is this like all one big marketing ploy
to be like oh it's in saudi arabia saudi
arabia wait what was the tweet saudi
arabia is converting an oil rig
into an amusement park for tourists the
park is called ring
okay i'll show you a rig
this is like a michael bay movie
what this is sick
[Applause]
uh go-karts yeah i'm going
yep i'm in there brother uh you want
this way
i'm going to do better we're in the
sweeper
this trailer makes this place look like
the best place on earth
the rig dot sa that looks lit honestly
yeah i want to go i'm gonna spend 20 000
to go there to stand in the go-kart line
all day hey man i think everyone's done
with the go-karts today i think we might
pack it up early now and i still want to
go yeah
you've done it 60 times today i think i
need 61.
yeah i could do better in turn three i i
kind of wish that it was
like they just opened it up to the
public but didn't change it like you
just went there and like worked on an
oil rig welcome to the rig oh i've heard
so many great things yeah none of it's
true just gonna work get in the suit
what
put the boots on and get in the suit
isn't this like massively dangerous
one of those one of the most dangerous
jobs on earth actually yeah yeah the
rate of death is like 97 or some [ __ ]
percent yeah i don't know
i don't know
something it's high brother
you want to put that suit on it's gonna
get hot yeah i thought it was like some
british petroleum thing where they're
like
i know we've poisoned like half the
ocean but we're here to show you that
oil can be fun it can be super fun
oil fountains although all the water is
taken from alaska it's like oil infested
water dead ass oil animals everywhere
there are seals in there but they're all
[ __ ] up they're covered in oil you
can't really see them but they like it
that's what we want you to see yeah yeah
like
they have oil spill simulator like it's
all like to tell you why it's good to
put oil in the ocean relive the magic
moment when we sunk the tanker in alaska
it's like this vr ride you're like
that sounds way better than go-karts
honestly yeah oh speaking of depressing
ass [ __ ] i started watching dopesick
that show is actually
so goddamn interesting so it's about
uh the distribution of oxy oxy
it's basically about i guess these two
families that co-owned a
uh
like a pharmaceutical type company
and the main villain
uh he i forget his damn name richard i
think
he comes up with with this idea to take
their system with this like 12-hour
release system and create it for oxy
oxy
and
uh
i guess originally it was used to treat
like
polio or
some something more intense
and they're saying once people got well
there'd be no reason for them to
distribute the drugs so it would eat
into their revenue at
25
so he comes up with the idea of
uh
changing the narrative and making pain
long-term
and then they would distribute uh
oxycontin and it would uh be something
that people could use regularly and the
whole uh
like ploy around it was that they were
able to get it approved by the fda like
a special label
so that
it was like a
second like a tier two narcotic but it
could be like
purchased over the counter or some [ __ ]
i forget
but the whole thing was rigged so that
they would make [ __ ] tons of money but
they're just turning people into addicts
like overnight i guess like
one you know 10 milligrams of oxy is
like
40 times as potent as morphine or
something it's like some crazy ratio
um
and it's kind of interesting like it
follows like
two sales people and like one of them is
like he's very clearly having a dilemma
because he's like uh [ __ ] and then
it uh michael keaton plays a doctor not
michael kane okay
michael keaton michael keaton michael
keaton
he plays a doctor okay that's uh
distributing oxy
and he
his whole position as a doctor is like
nah you would
he's like uh you would never give
narcotic for like regular pain
and because they got this label approved
they could say oh it's not addictive and
they're just flat out lying
and so
yeah they got like america hooked up on
this [ __ ] it's all one big scam you're
just like they just got away with that
and this is all we get on the other side
is like some shitty tv show
that's bad yeah it's like they still got
a bajillion dollars yeah
it's nuts and
kids everywhere are still dying every
single day from the show
so dark is it like depressing the show
honestly
no because all the scenes kind of feel
like a slightly better reenactment of
like an a and e show you know like where
they have like the talking head it's
like oh i worked for the dea from 81 to
87 yeah and then they cut to like two
horrible actors yeah
those the scenes kind of feel like that
because i don't think there's
realistically a way to be very detailed
about what happened right
so all the dialogue is really generic
wait
is it safe to double the dosage couldn't
that make them addicted i don't know all
i know is i'm going to win that vacation
at the end of the sale conference you're
like oh okay
but so it like it kind of kind of takes
the edge off
nice
nice
drugs yeah i mean it is depressing but
it is interesting just the
the sheer [ __ ] evil yeah and like i'm
curious to see where the where the story
like nets out not a happy ending no but
the company that distributed purdue
purdue pharma
i'm picturing one of them trying to come
out being like well the way they told
that story wasn't entirely accurate it's
like well let's look at all the dead
teenagers yeah see what they have to say
about it and to take like a subject like
that and make it not
so depressing yeah because that's when
you could go full a24 and like show
people overdosing and then people quit
on episode two yeah so they kind of
that's euphoria though
no euphoria is like
what if
kids did drugs but it was just a music
video yeah
for 17 hours
like doing coke and [ __ ] look really
cool just like
oh my god this is like my favorite new
modern song
maybe i should try cocaine oh my gosh is
that zendaya getting high i love that
she's so hot
especially when she's high watching
zendaya slay on euphoria made me want to
do co yeah sam
so romantic did you watch you i can't
get into that show man you
i just i can't [ __ ] care it just
feels like
they tried to get in on dexter you know
dexter was over there's tons of these
horny people that like want to see a
serial killer like what if he took a
dude like who looks like john mayer
made him a serial killer
there's a lot of sex
that's one of the best shows ever is it
is it
it's one of the best shows ever man is
it
you sure you're not just bricked up the
whole time just like
why is that why is that
murder yeah why is murder sexy
i don't dude it's like why are all these
girls like weirdly attracted to serial
killers i don't know i was weird i don't
know man it
that part to me i did i was scrolling
down my for you page on tick tock and i
like just want like this you know it was
like a girl in like a bikini
so she's like you know
she's doing like a thirst trap thing
clearly just like look at look at my
[ __ ] look what i got going on
and
the caption was something like
uh
don't mind the serial killer documentary
in the background like this girl's like
like dumping them out on tiktok and
meanwhile people are like dying on the
tv behind her like brutal murders
happening no just like what the [ __ ]
yeah i don't know
even the way they like portray his
going to be murders they're so like
they're horned up like crazy yeah are
you the one for me
can you be the one it's like he's going
to kill this one yeah yeah i know
stabbed this white woman joe is so hot
oh god i wish my stalker looked like
that is that just like a suburban girl
fantasy to be like i wish a man would
move into my neighborhood and [ __ ]
pay attention to me and then kill me and
make me hiss forever yeah we're watching
that show melina's like this show was
great i'm like
all right
yeah let me just come home tomorrow with
a [ __ ] knife in hand yeah she's like
you want a role play
maybe we should buy a glass box
i can spend some time in there all day
you like you like the movie you so much
i bought a house with a basement
i put a glass box in there i'm gonna
lock you in there
shouldn't have i'm gonna forget about
you
she's down there role playing with
herself oh god
he's not gonna kill me now is he
i sure hope
my scary stalker boyfriend doesn't come
come down and torture me right now
wow
techno is way harder on being safe jesus
christ
i said i sure hope he doesn't come down
right now
as i've been in this glass box for like
two hours now it's starting to get not
fun
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
having vr sex
oh how could i sit on those tv
[Laughter]
or just [ __ ] when i was on the way
less time
[Laughter]
[Music]
where were you i've been down here for
two hours i was skiing
[Laughter]
what slalom yeah slalom skiing was crazy
that's crazy at this guy in vr chat he's
like i know a sick mountain
we just went and we were just skiing for
like three hours it was
good guy anyways you were down here the
whole time
i left the key in the top thing you
could
you come out whenever